apparently a flagrant two [ __ ] army
member sent mark a picture of champagne
poppy Drake is out here photoshopping
his images breath it is embarrassing and
you know what it's one thing to go get
the surgery it's one thing to get makeup
it's one thing to dress in all the
coolest clothes it's another thing to
Photoshop your images to make it even
more unrealistic than you're already
unrealistic like crazy dude
it should be almost leaving it's like do
one of the other bro you either get the
surgery or you get the photo so for
clarity someone showed us a picture of
champagne poppies Instagram and then a
picture of Sophie it's champagne poppy
and if you're watching a video you can
see it if you're listening we'll
describe so champagne poppy
Sophie bruh sucks or whatever her name
sucks besides and then their kid it's
all three of them yeah he posted picture
and she posted the same picture now her
picture has been photoshopped blatantly
or his well we know her at first glance
her picture is overtly Photoshop because
they both have blonde hair like Adonis
picture real quick for smart so it's
Drake and Sophie with blonde hair to
match Adonis is hair that's the joke
this kid has blonde he looks like our
kid now so now they made Drake kind of
look like Eminem with the bleached
blonde hair she has blonde hair and the
kid has blonde curly hair they're a big
happy family
everything's fine but then if you look
closer to the image you notice that the
hair is not the only thing that's been
photoshopped and we don't know who's
doing the photoshopping it might be both
of them now click back quickly to
Drake's image the exact same image but
Drake's version if you notice and we're
gonna do a back and forth click I want
you to pay attention to something you're
probably already looking at the tits
look at the tits right now and now click
back to Sophie's origin which this are
noticeably what awesome Haller knows to
be smaller her stomach is noticeably
flatter but in Drake's image it actually
goes even further in so yeah it's like
concave it's concave so one would one
would believe either
she made her tits look smaller in her
version yeah or Drake made her tits look
bigger in his version and here's why I
think Drake did the photoshopping first
of all I'm a Drake hater I acknowledge
that yep but also if you look at Drake
and you go back and forth between
picture and picture look if you look at
the Drake picture Drake look brolic
posture up shoulders hot traps looking
huge and then if you look at the Sophie
picture suddenly he looks a lot skinnier
not that he's in bad shape but he don't
look as a broad like his shoulders sit
lower got a little more slouch less trap
so I would assume she's not gonna
Photoshop Drake to look less swoll
unless she's spiteful
so you're saying Drake photoshopped
himself to look more muscular and have
bigger shoulders bigger traps and made
his Sophie bruh sucks looked like she
had bigger titties in a slimmer waist
yes that makes more sense to me than her
making her titties look small or her
stomach more natural and him look
skinnier I want you to I'm hoping that
this is there's not true what I'm
thinking right now switch images real
quick go again go again go again
okay look Adonis I'm looking at Donna
fortunately a Photoshop to Thomas I
don't think they touched him up there
his hair that's the joke I think that
his hair more blunt yeah for hers I
think she like bleached everybody's hair
blonde but wow man
she significantly reduces the size of
her right titty I mean I wonder I really
wonder if every single picture that they
post or that Drake posts he basically
sends somebody he's like yo make this
picture the best picture it can be you
know cuz I have a friend who will remain
nameless but he has somebody who
photoshop's his images before they hit
Instagram he has just a kiss
say it that's hysterical it is
hysterical and it'd be even funnier if
you knew who was but basically before
they hit Instagram they get Photoshop to
basically bring out the color I like to
make the physique or anything look
different but
the color and he needs it so shall see
you ever but uh so basically if you're a
famous person and social media is so
important to you yeah you would think
you would think that there is a vetting
process for every picture it's not
they're just throwing a picture up like
me and you they're sending it to their
social media guy who makes sure their
skin looks immaculate that their face
looks even everything looks perfect
weight real quick is her is his watch
cut out of her no it's just the images
cut okay yeah I mean but I mean
everyone's doing this though that's the
thing everybody is [ __ ] doing it
every Instagram model because they're
doing it because of you Photoshop I
don't know you Photoshop your photos it
costs you a hundred bucks a pic you make
ten times that by being hotter yeah yeah
no I understand it for Instagram hoes
whose only talent is to be hot Drake is
even from the biggest Drake hater
supremely talented yeah what do you need
to do this for can we bring up her porn
is that weird so look at the head and go
can we bring up her porn but her porn
how was that it wasn't it wasn't even
porn I should just like rubbing oil go
Benny when I just can't believe it dude
come on drink face shape is a little bit
more full to in the photo shot one his
face with a little bit skinnier in the
in the in her version a little more like
stretched out yeah I don't know I mean
what a shame it can't be the case fellas
please stop Photoshop in your butt just
like you know rappers auto-tune not
Facebook man you can't do this man
just stop it you realize how much harder
you're making it on yourself you know we
can't do what women do right like women
had this we haven't had it perfect
they're the only ones with [ __ ] and
we had to [ __ ] them yeah and they got so
competitive they started shaving their
[ __ ] and waxing this and add
[ __ ] eyelashes they're just making
their life more difficult trying to have
a competitive advantage versus each
other right now
it's like free market capitalism hit
[ __ ] and then it never looked back you
know and now they have to go through all
this [ __ ] that they put on
themselves if we stripped everything
everyone went back to normal you're
gonna get the same guys Yeah right it's
like that girl that puts on all the
makeup when she goes out you're not
gonna trick a guy for more than a night
yes right you're gonna trick out one
night next morning he's gonna see your
face on his face an easy bag okay I'm
not gonna holla at that girl anymore
so you're still gonna end up with the
guy you're supposed to be with the guy
that accepts you for who you are because
at the end of day you're gonna have to
wake up with who you are so cut the [ __ ]
out if everybody just goes yeah we're
not doing any more and it's done nothing
changes all we ever had to work on
before is our personality that's it
be funny be charming who's not that hard
yes that's not an hour in the gym four
times a week you need an [ __ ] steamed
broccoli and chicken breast that's just
[ __ ] on each other to the point that
you sharpen your tool starving it that's
hey it was so easy
stop thinking ugly girls don't get late
there's Irish people born every day why
why it's there you're gonna get laid
you're gonna find someone that
appreciates you respect you loves you
we're all holding ourselves up to this
ridiculous [ __ ] standard we gotta
stop it maybe that's one thing the
coronavirus help
[Music]